Nadia what do you like about the journey
of pursuing acting versus the journey of
becoming a filmmaker hmm that's a really
good question yeah I think that when you
are looking to be in the career as an
actress you are really dependent on a
lot of other people's opinions and
permission and when you're a filmmaker
you can really initiate your own
projects you can be creative all of the
time you don't have to you don't have to
wait for someone to give you an audition
or to cast you in a role you can just go
out on your own and make a film and I
definitely think that was like part of
the decision you know back in my mid-20s
after being an actress for like ten
years in Canada that I felt like I
wanted a more kind of like full and rich
experience that I was also able to not
control but like to to really own and to
make you know my destiny mine right and
I want to come back to that in just a
little bit but I'm just curious with the
people garden which is the film that's
just come out right it was last week
yeah yeah when did you begin writing it
because I thought it was a while ago it
is yeah I started getting the idea back
in college and university in my last
year and I did other things in between
but it's been about six years so yeah so
like for me it was the first film that I
really wrote so there was taking your
time and learning how to write a feature
during the process of actually writing a
feature that's one thing and then the
other thing is that in Canada we have a
funding system such that you get
development money and that's really
wonderful because you can make a living
as you're making it writing a film but
it also it takes a while it takes a long
time so there was a lot of you know
years in between kind of that initial
idea and just you know of me just doing
other things whether it be acting or
other film work or directing or whatever
but so you know you're writing and
making it and shaping it for now it's
been about yeah six years yeah six years
yeah
remember like the day whether you were
in class or was there a spark where you
said okay I need to really do this this
is what I want to do no it's I can't
remember that far back as to like
exactly what what it was but there was a
combination of being immersed I did a
film Theory degree at university and
you're so that's meaning like it's not a
practical it's a it's you're studying
film it's an academic program so you're
writing about films and you're watching
films and you're critiquing them and you
know I was very immersed in this auteur
cinema and the great oh tours are often
men and when you're female and you want
to have you have aspirations of being a
director it becomes really frustrating
because on one hand like I was you know
loving the worlds that were created by
people like David Lynch or VIN vendors
or Jim Jarmusch or you know what those
people are like you know my heroes in a
way but they also do kind of male driven
films and I wanted someone like me that
I could kind of connect with and I
remember seeing this film called Morvan
collar by Lynn Ramsay right around the
same time that I saw The Virgin Suicides
by Sofia Coppola and suddenly those were
like two films that had females in the
lead and they had females that were
directing it and and I started to think
like you know it was possible to kind of
make this kind of cinema that I wanted
to make and so then I started writing
and that's where the idea kind of
started and then there was another side
to it which was that I was in a Japanese
cinema and literature class as part of
my studies and we were studying this
this kind of very dark and very strange
book called the complete manual to
suicide and that's where I read about
the forest so everything was kind of
just happening and percolating in my
mind and I just started you know writing
and developing and really working on
this character sweetpea more than
anything and just just to know that
there is a real forest in Japan where
people yeah is it you say that they go
there to commit suicide or they have
count
there because so many people commit
citizen yeah both yeah it's this it's a
very it's like the Golden Gate Bridge in
San Francisco it's infamous for being a
place where people might go and either
consider it or or do that and it became
such a frequent event that they have
these forest workers who work there and
their job is to basically counsel you if
you need it be there for you if you want
but not necessarily to deter you in any
way from making that choice
I was really particularly struck when I
was researching the the forests that
they have like these like hazard signs
almost like you know like we would have
like stop signs or yield signs but they
have these signs there and they'll say
like throughout the forest like please
consult your bank please consult your
family please like so these actual kind
of like warning signs it's so like the
forest is so known now that they
actually have these kind of like this
like bureaucracy almost around it and
that struck me as also being like oddly
darkly humorous too like that there's
this effort to try to stop people from
like what is one of the the most like
personal choices that a human being
could ever make and so like I don't know
though if it to me the place itself just
had all of these like heightened
emotions and that becomes you know like
often very compelling for an artist to
kind of go there and look into it I
think I heard you say in a Q&A which
just really struck me that you would
either research a fellow search and
rescue worker and that at the most
beautiful part of any sort of area where
they find bodies I mean I should say
that that's where they find the body and
you just said something really no I mean
it's it's it's the one thing that stayed
with me the most when I was researching
the forest because they they have you
know people commit suicide and in forest
not just in the Japanese forest and I
happen to know someone whose brother was
a
search-and-rescue person in a forest in
Vancouver in Canada and he didn't like
to talk about it but I told him what my
intentions were and he was so gracious
enough to give me his time and insight
and what he said to me which something
that just stayed from the very beginning
which was that they always knew where to
look for the bodies because inevitably
it was in the most beautiful part of of
the forest like a stream or a cliff and
I found that like like the most human
thing in the world that no matter what
even in our darkest times like we still
endeavour to find beauty like even in
that last moment that we're looking for
beauty I still get chills like it's been
like six years like talking about it and
I think that like we're all trying like
to do that you know like I I think that
we're all trying to find something that
makes life meaningful and count and some
form of beauty and I think that to me it
just was like a very full of pathos
thing to hear this man describe that and
the way that he also and listening to
how he described it as well like he he
he had this almost like banality towards
death like he he himself because he had
seen it it it was regular it's like when
you talk to a doctor someone who has
seen death you know that's part of life
is death you know so we kind of
romanticize it or are scared of it or
feel this like great fear towards it but
you know for him it was like this
happens we clean it up and again like I
think that like that's a very powerful
sort of thing to investigate and like
for me that kind of just I wanted to
learn more about that that side of
things and investigate that a little bit
through these characters how long did it
take you to write the script for the
people garden yeah it took me like on
and off six six years I think from from
the initial idea and developing it to
maybe five years - right - we started
shooting but then
yeah so okay it's been like I thought a
six year process so and that was the not
the first draft though it sounds like
did you you did revisions oh yeah for
revisions forever and always yeah it's a
funny thing like again like I'm Canadian
we have a particular system there and
development is really really big and in
our community so you know there's
multiple drafts over those years and
there's input from producers and input
from you know story editors and you go
back and you rewrite so yeah what I love
about the film too is it's it's not so
heavy on dialogue yeah it's really like
it breathes you feel what these
characters are going through you see it
in the eyes and did you tone back any of
the writing was it overly worried before
yeah for sure yeah I love writing
dialogue so I will kind of go there
which is probably I think it immature
way to write I'm not sure I don't know
depends on who you talk to but so I
there was a lot of dialogue and then as
you're kind of working on it and
revising it you're pulling back and
trying to think of economy and I think
also because the film I wanted to it's a
to me it's a romance film people will
say it's like a horror film or thriller
or what that it's not it's a romance
film really and but it has this like
mystery to it so for me I really wanted
to like have this engagement with the
audience of trying to figure out what is
happening and the the less narrative
structure that you can not structure but
the less narrative information that that
you have the more an audience can like
activate their own sort of mind and
start to try to figure things out and I
love that involvement so but it takes
practice to get to hone that and to
bring it down to like you know a very
simple simple place of dialogue it also
came from jury because jury is so great
when she's still and she's not you know
I think you know I'm chatty hope you can
tell that but so sweet Pete was like a
little bit more chatty before but drew
when you after I cast her you know
you you start to move towards people's
strengths and she's so good at just kind
of being very still and having it be in
her eyes so that became part of the
character in the film as well yeah and
Pam as well like especially the
interactions between the two of them
happy sort of unspoken thing and it's it
was really fun to like film as well and
you're right like just like that way
that they look at each other it becomes
more telling than anything they could
really say sure sure and the smiles that
were you know a lot of showing yeah
interesting I won't give too much away
but um so in terms of the dialogue were
there people that gave you feedback
because I feel like it's the perfect
amount it's it's just enough but it's it
doesn't sort of overly like you know it
doesn't micromanage the the viewer in
terms of telling them too much yeah for
sure I mean again like I think that the
idea became that the that you wouldn't
have as much of a backstory to that
character that there wouldn't be too
much information about her that you you
would lock in with her right off the bat
and then and then just go on this
journey with her and experience the
forest exactly at the same time that she
was experiencing it and that became like
a really big part of like what I wanted
the audience interaction to be was to to
identify with her and not know anything
more than she does for the majority of
the film until there's there's a certain
point where I think the audience is
ahead of her they sort of know what I
think the audience knows what's going on
and she might still not have figured it
all out and that becomes I think an
emotional engagement where you you've
kind of bonded with this character and
you're suddenly like no don't like
you're doing it wrong you're going down
the wrong path you're you're going about
this the wrong way and that becomes kind
of dramatically interesting so that's
that's what I wanted to play with yeah
right okay yeah definitely I I do see
that and then you feel for her and then
you're almost like this parent behind
the scenes yeah protect her absolutely
when you begin writing do
you outlined you do is you know sort of
the the all the yeah no cookie cutter
screenwriting formatting that you're
supposed to do well I try now I think
there's like two types of writers they
say it's like intuitive writer and then
someone made fun of me the other day
because I couldn't remember what it was
and they said well that means that
you're an intuitive writer but it's like
structured writer versus intuitive
writer so I'm an intuitive writer that's
first like so I I have to force myself
to write the outline because I would
just like to actually start writing
that's how I work I see things very
visually I see it in my mind I want to
put it down on paper that usually means
it takes a little bit of time to finish
a script too because I think without
that kind of like those natural steps of
like outline first draft second draft
and and you know there were all of those
things but I I would write an outline so
that I could send it to my producer and
that he you know would understand it but
for me when my process what works for me
is is to like just get in there and
start writing but I'm trying to be
better I'm trying to be more more
disciplined in the way yeah because I
mean especially like what I'm writing
like television as well right now and
you know it has to be more disciplined
so but it's a process like I'm still
learning for sure I felt it flowed very
naturally so whatever you're doing thank
you did you get funding in the very
beginning and then started honing the
story or did you reach out to the actors
first how did that all work so when I
was in school so I did like I did a
degree like a college degree and then
after that I went to this place in
Canada called the Canadian film center
and it's like our version of the AFI
basically so I went I was writing it
there
as well this script and your they give
you the means to like make a little
short so I made a little short about it
as well that no one will ever see
hopefully ever it's terrible actually
it's alright but so I I did that and
then with that short I approached a
producer in in Toronto that I was
interested in that I had actually worked
with as an actress who was doing really
really interesting work and then yeah
and then we went to the funders with our
collective experiences that short and an
outline and then they give us a little
bit of money to write the first draft
and then once we were in that once we
had the first draft then we actually got
like a little more substantial money for
sort of each subsequent draft so yeah I
mean Canada's really great that way
because we have a government system set
up to support the Arts and if you can
get into that system it's also like
highly debated system by multiple
filmmakers as you can understand who are
living in Canada because you know if you
don't get funding it you're sort of left
out but if you end up being a part of
that that system then you can you know
you can you can make an OK living for I
mean you are getting yeah they're they
acknowledge that you know you have to
take time off of your like teaching job
or your you know your side projects or
whatever to concentrate on the script so
there there is that ability yeah
progressive in yahweh's yeah absolutely
they do that in Europe as well I mean
Americas is you know the capitalistic
society here and that you know that
works a lot for film as well so there's
a lot of problems in the Canadian system
but but there is that kind of belief
that there's like true value in culture
in supporting you know arts that's great
did you write with these various actors
in mind or was dead that come later yeah
that came much later I had I had some
people in in mind writing it and in a
way like I think that that would have
been
dad if I would have got those actors
because I think that you you can only
like it becomes much more interesting
then because it you go from writing to
directing and then it's a completely
different set of like thinking and
analytical skills and you know I think
that the cast that I ended up with like
really helped create and write the story
with me in a way - because their
personalities I redid some rewrites one
after I cast for sure oh yeah before we
started shooting and the G and the James
lagrua the director I had just worked
with him as an actress and if we got
along like a house on fire he's amazing
and so I really wanted him to play that
part and he he's hilarious and wry and
like grumpy kind of in a way that is
like amazing and I was like I'm just
writing this character to like suit you
the most and you know luckily he ended
up doing it but he was the only one that
I kind of really wrote it I did think
about Pamela for signais early on - I
was like there's no way we'll get her oh
the fact that we actually yeah did is is
pretty great so who was the first actor
that you presented the script to and how
did it go yeah I think I mean dree was
the first person that we that we cast
drew Hemingway who plays sweet pea and
that was obviously like the most
important character in the film and it
you kind of had to figure things out
around whoever was going to be cast in
that role so I had seen starlet which is
this really great film that she did that
she carries in in so many ways and you
know I was saying to earlier that I
didn't know after I saw starlet if she
was right for the role as I had written
it I didn't see it right away but I
loved her in that film and I liked also
like her her persona like outside of
being an actress she's kind of like this
I don't know like model I guess but she
has this connection with like young
girls and that's exactly who I wanted to
this film to kind of get to so she's
stuck in the back of my head
then you know it's like just like a
classic like our casting director
mentioned her and she they sent her the
script and she called me yeah she called
me and she loved the script and she she
read for it and she was so natural and
beautiful and like committed and just
ready like present which is really
really hard to do in an audition so I
just knew she was like an excellent
actress up you know that starlet wasn't
a fluke and became really clear to me
that like she was exactly the right
person for the role because you know she
is so natural and subtle and she just
has like so much that's just happening
in her eyes the kind of actress that I
really love and the world around her is
a bit I don't want to say surreal but
it's a little bit off kilter and it's
you know some of the characters around
her are a bit like arch and so having
someone who's really grounded and like
subtle for the audience to identify with
I think this was the right choice and
like it couldn't have worked out better
I think she's so extraordinary and like
raw and the film just like honest she's
just very honest in the film right right
and she and as she is in starlet but
you're right it's two different
composites of totally different
characters life situations yes and yeah
for sure and in some of the smaller
roles that she's had in some bigger
films like she's often quite kind of
like funny and like you know goofy and I
think that's important for also a role
like this which is not like a funny role
but you want there to be a lightness to
it cuz it can't all be it takes you know
there's suicide in the in the film and
but it can't all be dark it can't be so
heavy that people are like you know
overcome with you know sadness watching
it I didn't want to depress people
watching it you know I wanted to make
people feel but so she's right for that
reason as well because there's this kind
of soulfulness but she still kind of has
a light touch you know yeah and that's
what I was afraid when I first was going
to watch it that I would be but I didn't
feel it throughout most of it I felt
fairly like it was it was like a mystery
and yeah there are parts that are
you know it's especially to the
interaction between the two of the women
in the film and I'm curious how did you
cast Pam yeah I mean like I said that
Pam did enter my mind when I was when I
was writing it but I kind of said no
that's that's not gonna happen that's
impossible but we had a I mean first of
all she had done this interview on like
The Ellen DeGeneres Show she came out
and she hadn't been interviewed for a
while she hadn't done something stuff
for a while she came out she had cut all
her hair off like she's really short and
gamine and like she looked like she was
a Godard girl like she just looked like
she was not at all like the kind of
persona that you would see seen and when
she was talking on that film on that
show um you know she she was very funny
and very like self-deprecating and she
was self-aware and I thought like the
person who needs to play Signet has to
be like very self-aware of that persona
so I started kind of like the wheels
were turning and then the casting
director that we had had been casting a
Verner Herzog film that she was supposed
to be in which again like you wouldn't
think Verner Herzog and Talia Anderson
but apparently it was like very close to
happening and then I just like things do
fell apart and she was looking for a
script and they sent it to her and again
she called she called me from Malibu I
got this like phone call was like in
Toronto in my bedroom and this call from
it was Pam we talked for an hour and a
half she was so easy to talk to she
really understood the character she
really understood you know what I was
trying to do with the relationship
between those two women and how their
kind of their versions of the same
character in a way like in a way I feel
like sweetie you could have gone on in
her life had she stayed with Jamie to be
a signais in a way because in my mind
like I have a backstory for Sweet Pea
although it's not really kind of talked
about in the film as much but to me I
just felt like there was like this
connection that those two women had
because they recognized them
elves in each other even though they
were enemies she got that right away she
knows so much about art she knows so
much about film you know so you can talk
to somebody you can talk about
references we had some like amazing
conversations about Fellini women and
and all you know all these things and
and she's she's really the coolest she's
like absolutely the coolest yeah yeah
reminds me of just kind of like the
Marilyn Monroe stereotype but then when
you would read things that she would say
you know it just it just shows that that
was the one image that was presented but
it didn't mean that that was the full
package and definition yeah and I think
she really actually uses like Marilyn
Monroe as like kind of like I know she
really you know respects her and
respects that that you know career that
Marilyn you know had and the fact that
there was it was almost like acting like
that persona is very much a persona and
Pam is very aware of of that and she can
play with that go in and out of it it's
very fascinating yeah that's really
interesting I think you said something
I'd like it to just be seen as a
filmmaker not like it's different or
special and and I realized that there is
a lot of pressure in an interviewer
asking that the woman question yeah and
maybe just you can just touch on that
just just how it's just yeah so that's
not different or special or whatever
it's just a filmmaker yeah I mean I
think what I meant by that to was that
often in interviews like a lot of my
colleagues who are men and at the same
kind of level as I am you know just with
their first or second film they got
asked about their process you know as
you're asking they get asked about their
films they their film gets interpreted
and watched with a critical eye that but
when you're a female filmmaker they want
to know what it's like being a female
making films and I think that's part of
the problem because I think that like we
can't be taken at the same level as our
male colleagues until there is some sort
of sense of you know that the choices
that we're making like I you know just
as an aside I read a review of this film
and the guy said it you know that it was
you know pretty I was like you know it's
a visual medium
so it's going to but like you know but
that was his kind of like one thing and
I was like no if it was a male who had
done like a visually interesting or
compelling thing you would have said
something more you would have mentioned
the cinematographers name you would have
mentioned the production designers name
maybe or but-for and I felt I mean I
might be wrong but it felt gendered like
it felt as though it was dismissive like
of course a girl is gonna make us a
pretty film you know but that's like not
thoughtful so for me it's like on the
one hand like I'm a very strong a
feminist and on a very unapologetic
about it and unspoken and but no I mean
no buts that's a full stop but but it
would be great to get to a point I'm
sure for all female filmmakers where we
can just be asked about you know the
work yeah I get it
you know journalists play a part in that
and I owe ya but I later I respect the
fact when you know journalists are
asking you but you know the female
question because it's been untalked
about for so long you know diversity is
now something that we're we're able to
talk about and have a dialogue with and
it is great so it's great to be asked
about that way I just like it to be also
like followed up with some questions
about the actual like the piece itself
you know well the film is clearly more
than just pretty I mean there's a deeper
message in it and I think I heard you
touch on a little bit and just how
talking about happiness and and what we
go after is it really fulfilling or just
the title of it seems good yeah so I
think you touched on that as well as it
being a romance and then the dynamics
that happen within a romance so yeah
yeah there's there's more to it than
just the visuals so thank you yeah
absolutely even though it also to me it
is yeah the visuals are our huge part of
the storytelling you know as well so I
don't mind if people like respond at all
you know to that but obviously pretty
it's just kind of a little bit
dismissive to the work that went into it
oh I agree and and there is one scene
that is very beautiful that is the one
where Pam Anderson is like fly her
her role in the film is this model that
comes into this relationship and I'll
just keep it there but that the rain
coming down and I think you would
mention that you really love that scene
I do yeah yeah I love that scene there's
a lot I mean there's there's there's a
few scenes we got right but that's a
very visual scene for sure I think it's
fairly you know also as it goes back to
this idea of like beauty and that we as
human beings endeavour to find beauty so
in one kind of hand I think there's a
little bit of critique in the film to
what what we go after and how we try to
find our happiness or how we try to find
our beauty and what we're willing to
kind of not see in order to find that
happiness and I think that the music
video shoot within that and and Pamela's
role is like you know those filmmakers
are presented in the film as being you
know callous I think and and
unthoughtful and they are you know I
think that they know more that they
could be telling Sweet Pea in there and
they're not and they're kind of
dismissive of the fact that a human
being has gone missing
you know on the other hand they're
trying to create something that they
find kind of and you it's undeniable
that when that music video is being shot
and she's up in the air that that is an
image of beauty and that there's
validity to that so it's like playing
with those two sort of ideas of you know
those kind of the lies that we tell
ourselves and the the sort of facades
that we create and the beauty that we
focus on you know versus what's
underneath and the kind of how you need
both you you really need you need to
find the balance of those kinds of
things in in life so yeah did you have
an agent or manager before you made the
film or or did that come later I don't
actually have an a manager an agent even
at now I did all this been taking
meetings
yeah I mean again like I made this film
in in Canada and outside of the American
system and like you know we obviously
have Americans in the film and yet an
American casting director but in Canada
it's not as may be necessary to have an
agent or I don't know just didn't feel
didn't I already had my producer and I
had a agent for acting but but now it's
like yeah there's oh I'll get one one of
these days I I just am very selective
yeah I was watching a film on
screenwriting the other day and this guy
was talking about when he's really in it
with his writing and he's just
I mean he's creating these incredible
worlds everything else around him falls
apart yeah anybody who's creative can
probably relate to that is there
anything you can touch all oh my god I
think he just become so immersed in it
that like I wouldn't say that things
like fell apart around me but I would
say that you are negligent towards like
you know friends and and family because
you're just in that world you're so it
takes as you know like so much to get a
film off the ground and once you're in
it and so you you know there you
definitely that sort of life work
balance doesn't always work for the
duration but I've also kind of been in
the industry for a while so that I know
how to manage that and my friends you
know know my family know that just like
everything's gonna be shut off for a
while and I'll come back to you and I'll
make it up to you right yeah and so the
screening is in LA tonight yeah it's
playing at the downtown independence
tonight in LA and for the next week and
it's playing across the states and
select cities small release small film
but and then online so it's available on
American iTunes starting now as well
right yeah so people can if you've got a
chance to see it in the better on a
bigger screen because of some of the
imagery that's in there but obviously
but it's just as good getting curled up
and watch
in your home so I think you said earlier
was six years that it kind of took to
really come to fruition but can you take
a step by step in terms of putting the
words on the paper to being in
production where you're in the forest
and you're shooting it yeah I mean
that's a la a long time to cover so I
probably can't do it step by step but
you know for the first year it's a lot
of research and just testing out writing
like I said this was the first thing
that I wrote as a full as a full film so
you know you're learning also how to
screen right you know what in a way as
you're writing it so there is you know
we had a story editor on about maybe a
year after I started writing so that's
when it became a lot more structured in
terms of like delivering drafts or
delivering rewrites so I think that we
would like probably every two weeks or
something have him have a meeting maybe
every month where we were giving notes
like my producer who I worked with on
this and I had made a short with before
same as Dan Becker I mean you know he
really like shepherded this film right
from the beginning and I trust him in
his taste and he he just did this really
huge movie called the witch
I don't know if you had seen it was like
this really huge kind of artistic horror
film so he's he's certainly on the rise
but this was a smaller film of his and
so he would you know come over to my
house you know with the story editor and
we'd sit around and drink coffee and go
through the notes and and hash it out
and then and then we'd have to go away
and work to make the living and do other
kind of jobs a little bit as well and
then then we'd come back to it and I'd
say like that sort of happened for I
maybe like four years and then you start
the application process for like then
you have a script that is ready oh I
know one other thing that happened was
which was really important for making
this film was
I did this lab at TIFF at the Toronto
International Film Festival had a
screenwriter screenwriting lab like it's
similar to how like Sundance is but it
was the inaugural year and I had applied
with this script and it was a workshop
with like another yet another story
editor - from like Sweden we would Skype
it was like this very kind of
interesting experience where she was
completely out of kind of the the group
of screenwriters and writers and
filmmakers that I was used to so she was
a totally fresh eyes on this project and
that script one like my script won the
Audience Award for that so it was
awarded something and then we kind of
fast-tracked to production so that's
when we were able to approach the
Canadian funding bodies and ask for
money for for making the film and that's
a very long process I don't know if it's
boring or not but it's a you know there
were a lot of in putting all the
financing together for this film
it was it was really tricky no it was
just really really tricky because of the
budget level and because of certain kind
of funding that we got because there's
different funding agencies in Canada so
we actually had to shoot some of it in a
certain geographical location in Canada
so all the interiors are done in Ontario
and the exteriors are Japan and NBC oh
okay so that's like that would be like
the equivalent of like doing only
interiors in New York and exteriors in
LA or something I mean it's like that
far apart between like Sudbury Ontario
and NBC and then obviously Japan so yeah
and then like the you know the lead-up
to actually this day of shooting there
was like three intense months of prep
six months of soft prep like location
scouting and everything I mean that was
like a that's a blur like that's it was
so intense during those those final
three months that we were all getting
sick and we were
like it was like but it was but it was
amazing you're thrilling cuz you know
what's gonna happen and then just that
like first day of shooting I remember I
remember that super vividly and the
shoot itself was over the course of
about a month and a half with a break in
the middle which is also unusual but
that was part of it because of the Japan
portion and so yeah three different
crews based on the different regions
other than the keys like the
cinematographer obviously the same and
production designer but all that like
different gaffer a different so it's all
that kind of like learning curve as well
with each new crew and Wow so a lot and
this is the first yeah yeah I mean you
just I mean I think that's part of like
what you know it took so long because we
knew we had to do it at a certain budget
and it's still incredibly low budget
compared to what is out there like we're
at like 1.2 million dollars but they're
not they don't give that to you just for
kind of nothing so you really have to be
prepared and ready to go and when it all
happened so yeah it was a huge learning
curve I mean yeah it was it was very
challenging very thrilling I think if
you're in in film you probably love
problem solving you probably have that
kind of mind and I do like it feels
creative to me to like be given a
challenge or an obstacle and just be
like I got this I can do this analytical
thinking towards figuring it out and you
just do just put the pieces of the
puzzle together so so 1.2 million
Canadian dollars yeah which is what like
four dollars American yeah I don't know
what that worked out to but yeah and so
I would imagine so many of the steps
along the way it was where you were
either revising something and then
coming back to show them in order to yes
I mean the funny thing is that funding
agencies were pretty hands-off I've
heard other stories but they're pretty
hands-off with us in terms of content
they just wanted to see the drafts and
know that we were continuing along and
in terms of the creative input they
didn't give a ton of that so we were
kind of like really really lucky I
haven't heard that as being
Cesario Lee the case for you know other
other people but again because it's like
a government funding they're not really
necessarily creatives that are funding
it always there it's a bureaucracy it's
like it's a where it's a self like
country that finances art so they're you
know making sure that you're getting
your drafts in on time and that kind of
bureaucracy but they're not necessarily
like commenting on the content but they
might a little bit but it's not hard and
fast yeah so they're not saying you know
what can we make sweet pea more this
likable and all that yeah well I mean
but that's still like there was a lot of
input on the script process like all
along the way regardless of the funding
agencies because you're just showing it
to other people and you're just or
you're sending it to you know like that
like the the screenwriting lab or you
know we sent it to a Tribeca lab and you
know early on in the process you so
people are giving feedback in that sense
and yeah there's definitely of stories
of like that make you know sweet pea
more likable and you know sexy and I
don't know anything but yeah you just
have to kind of know what your know what
the story is or you're telling and try
to stay as flexible and open to other
people's thoughts but then ultimately
like know the best decision to be made
for the film that you were trying to
make cuz that's why they're giving you
the money is to hear your point of view
you know so did you do a script read
without everyone not what this cast no I
did melt to pull skipped script reads
along the way with like friends just to
hear it out loud but no there was no
like we I think like Matt the guy who
played the gentleman who plays Mac his
name is Jay West I think he's incredible
in the film finding him was like the
hardest thing I think we found him like
just in the nick of time it was very
hard to find someone who was Japanese
english-speaking Canadian but so he was
living in Tokyo and and but uh so but
also good you know and he is so I think
strong in this film and so yeah we you
know we were casting some of the other
parts like up until the last minute and
then everyone showed up and we were she
there was no no cast read no rehearsal
so and how did that that first day you
know that you have this incredible
budget albeit small by oh yeah yes but
still for us most filmmakers would
totally yeah I know I know ya salivate
over that yeah for sure how was that
first day you've got the people that you
you didn't think you'd get Pam Anderson
butter and trees there and I mean it's
an incredible feeling I'm not gonna it's
like the greatest it doesn't like I'll
be on my deathbed thinking of like that
that how good that all felt to have it
come together and to visualize things I
think one of the reasons to just going
back to something you you mentioned that
scene where Pamela's like in the air you
know and it doesn't it doesn't have
necessarily so much to do with the story
but I think one of the things about that
scene was like like so many of the other
scenes but that was also something that
you just had visualized it in my head
for so long and then it's literally
there and you know there was there was a
lot of scenes like that where it's like
it's been in your mind for so long and
then it's you know Katherine did a great
job of shooting it
Katherine lutes and you know production
designer social McKenzie and everyone
kind of makes that thing that's in your
head real and those actors come together
and they're all there and it's you know
drew looks exactly how you wanted her to
look she's like she's present in a way
that is like just it feels so good to
see that and that's the reward for all
that you know six years of everything
and that's the reward for like you know
being unemployed and just struggling for
money and that's the reward for bad
reviews and that's the reward for
everything it's just like that time
shooting when you actually get to like
make what is in your head real that's no
one get that's amazing like that's
that's an incredible feeling that I
think we all chase you know what genre
would you consider the people garden you
said it's so romance but then there's a
thriller
like John or less and that's kind of the
point a little bit for me like I don't
know why I'm when people talk about
diversity and plurality in storytelling
right now because they're talking about
it in terms of gender and race and you
know sexual preference and and I think
it's um I think that that is only
because we are craving new forms of
storytelling because we are a little bit
the the classical narrative male-driven
heroic Hollywood narrative stories are
played out there's only so much of that
that we can that we can take and so I
think I'm like playing with genre like
I'm almost using it as a way of like
what she's going through
which like it's not nothing new I'm not
breaking any ground in that way to kind
of have a multi genre film but like you
know some people will really embrace
that and get that and love it and some
people kind of won't but yeah I mean for
me it's like you know there's mystery
elements of romance you know it's darkly
humorous yeah dark it's also lights
hopeful I mean I don't know it's it's
its life it's like there's you know
there's a lot of what you experience
just some life did anybody try to push
you away from the suicide aspect because
it's not like a suicide heavy film where
you feel like oh my gosh I'm gonna be so
depressed you don't feel that but but
did did anybody try to say you know can
you just try it where she goes there for
something else and it's not that area
yeah I mean honestly like no I mean I
think not that I can necessarily recall
I mean I'm sure that there were people
that didn't like I'm sure there are
people that we approached for either
funding or some other kind of support
that you know wanted to stay away from
it but no I think that again I hate to
keep going back to the fact that it was
made in Canada but they're like I have a
little bit more people Know Who I am
because of acting and they know my
sensibility isn't a and I think like the
script it read even front from those
early drafts as having a kind of like a
lightness to it and that it wasn't just
like this heavy right
you know suicide film so ordinary people
or something like that yeah I mean but I
mean that's a great oh yeah yeah and
that's a fantastic film and there's been
you know there's been there's yeah
anyways but yeah there's yeah I think
like you said it's just not like it's
not a suicide right film no it's in
there obviously but but it's not a
central it is lamenting I mean there's a
kind of a difference then like I think
that had I set out to sort of answer it
answer suicide or you know make that the
topic of conversation then we'd be happy
it would have been a different film but
for me it was just more about this young
woman needing to face something in her
life that she was like ill-prepared to
face even though she thought she could
do it you know she's about her becoming
more vulnerable in a way like not you
know we'd see all these movies these
days where the females are coming
stronger and stronger and stronger and
in a way it's like the reverse in this
one like she's kind of she goes there to
you know break up with him I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this thing and then
she she kind of doesn't her plans don't
go her way she has to kind of face them
things but she hadn't been willing to
face before yeah that's interesting
you're right it is reverse what's your
typical day like when you're in
production or or the writing phase
what's your typical day
well writing I think is just very
different than being in the production
side of it writing I like to do a
nine-to-five
like usually 11 to 8 like I'm not I like
to structure my days so that I'm writing
it like an office job which is kind of
funny in a way because you kind of do
this job because you don't like the
office job but I like that kind of
structure because I like to be able to
have an end point for relaxation it
doesn't always work that way but like
relaxation meaning like watching movies
or just like thinking about something
else other than project because I think
that's so important just to stay like in
life as well so yeah I'll get up and you
know you know sit in front of my
computer not writing for a couple of
hours then write something maybe and go
make some lunch and come back and not
write something for a while and then go
back you know and then you just kind of
start and stop like any job and just do
that consistently though you know five
days a week for sure and in production
notes like just nothing just like no
sleep no no no emails no Twitter no like
nothing other than just the total
immerse immersion in in the project
there's just literally no I mean maybe
down the line if there's multiple zeros
added to budgets and you have you know
help maybe there's it's possible to kind
of have like a life I've heard these
like stories that like Lars von Trier
like ends up four and they all have
dinner and everything and that sounds
lovely but I can't picture it so there's
always problems to be solving or you
know there's always you know you're just
just in it for for production I think
you're just completely in that world and
only in that world do you want to do
something similar as your next project
or right now you can't even think about
that because no I yeah I'm back at it I
had like a break after I was finished
and finished the Edit was very long at
it as well and I had a break so that was
good but no I I love what I do so I'm
back at it I'm doing television I I have
a series that that the like the script
was optioned just recently in that I'm
making with some friends in Canada so
we'll see if that gets picked up but
that's kind of taking up my time right
now and I also am writing another
feature and I have another idea for a
television series so it kind of event
reading scripts as well because I also
love directing other people's work I
find that super fulfilling so no it's
it's back back in the immersion do you
see a lot of differences in Canadian TV
versus the u.s. yeah definitely yeah I
mean I
I'm but TV now can be like the TV in
Canada I think that we're aiming for is
the stuff where like Netflix or someone
like that also might be a part of it and
they're doing a little bit more
co-productions with Canada which is
really helpful but yeah I mean you guys
like America I mean you guys I'm here
now too but America has like some
excellent I think television don't you
think like I think it's all of the HBO
and the show Showtime
Hulu like all of those shows are
incredible they're all like they're the
independent cinema for me like though
that's where it's getting really kind of
interesting and gritty and like you know
chancy like not necessarily the network
I mean I think there's some interesting
things and us network television but all
of those ones that you watch on your
computer are really up there and I think
Canada's it's like a little bit behind
you know really oh yeah yeah oh yeah but
there but you know we're gonna we're
gonna make sure they catch up okay we're
trying yeah Nadia for someone that has a
script a feature-length film script that
they're done with then what's your
advice or where do they go with it
whether they're in the States whether
they're in Canada I know it's your Isis
half one a little bit I think you have
to have I think you have to find a
collaborator a producer type figure that
is a creative producer meaning someone
who is going to be able to understand
your vision for the work and that is
going to take it to the right people and
so that would be my main advice like I
don't necessarily know like how you get
things made I don't you know but we're
all figuring that out but having that
one backer that's gonna speak for you
because I think that like as
screenwriters or directors we sometimes
have a hard time putting ourselves out
there but you need that one producer
that understands you supportive of you
and is going to connect you to the
people that can you know pay for it and
and/or who are going to support it so
that would be my mind
vice is to try to find that that
creative partner on the journey that
you're about to take